[موسيقى]
يُطلق عليه اسم Candida Oris، وهو فطر
يمكن أن ينتشر بسهولة عبر مرافق الرعاية الصحية
ويحتمل أن يسبب
مرضًا مميتًا، لم نره إلا هنا في
الولايات المتحدة منذ عام 2016. ومنذ ذلك
الوقت، ارتفعت الحالات بشكل كبير، وتُظهر البيانات الجديدة لمراكز مكافحة الأمراض والوقاية منها
وجود 53 حالة في عام
2016.  قفز هذا العدد إلى ما يقرب من 1500
في عام 2021. في البداية كان يقتصر في الغالب
على منطقتي نيويورك وشيكاغو،
وهو الآن موجود في أكثر من نصف
الولايات الأمريكية. والمشكلة التي
نجدها مع الأسلحة الكندية هي أنها
أصبحت مقاومة للفيروس.  ثلاث فئات
من مضادات الفطريات التي
تقول مراكز السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها حاليًا إن الأشخاص الأصحاء لا
يمرضون عادةً من المبيضات RS، فمن
المرجح أن تؤثر على أولئك الذين يعانون من
مشاكل طبية خطيرة تتطلب
إقامة طويلة في مرافق الرعاية الصحية، والأشخاص الذين يعانون من
ضعف في جهاز المناعة وأولئك الذين
يحصلون على الأجهزة الطبية  في أجسادهم
مثل أنبوب التنفس أو القسطرة، تقول الدكتورة
كريستين إنجلاند من كليفلاند كلينك إن
مرافق الرعاية الصحية يجب أن
تعزل المرضى المصابين بهذه
العدوى الفطرية، ولا يقلق عامة السكان
بشأن
الشعور بالارتياح ليكونوا في حالة تأهب قصوى بقدر
التأكد من أننا  لن نستمر فيما يتعلق
بالأشخاص الآخرين إذا كنا نعرف شخصًا لديه
مجتمع من أجل الصحة، فأنا ماندي
جايثر